Donald Trump posting to truth social in
response to desantis's recent statements
about the Trump looming indictment which
we just looked at quote Rhonda
sanctimonious will probably find out
about false accusations and fake stories
sometime in the future as he gets older
wiser and better known when he's
unfairly and illegally attacked by a
woman even classmates that are underage
or possibly a man I'm sure he will want
to fight these Misfits just like I do
and again this is only a smear to
homophobic people right if I found out a
candidate I liked or was thinking about
supporting Were Gay I would say oh I
don't care about that what are their
policies